hi everyone welcome back so this is the
second video lecture on exponential
growth so in the first video I gave you
like a big overview of how important
exponential growth is it is ubiquitous
from technology to financial markets to
population dynamics and now in the
second video I'm going to zoom in to
kind of work out some systems that
exhibit exponential growth one of the
hallmarks how do we understand these
kind of big and growing numbers so
that's that's all we're going to talk
about now so when I talk about this in
class I like to think about this in
terms of a really really simple example
of a population of bunnies okay so we
all know what bunnies like to do bunnies
procreate okay so if I start out with an
initial population of bunnies let's say
two bunnies don't worry about any moral
implications of only starting with two
bunnies so if I start out with two
bunnies and we assume that they double
every year then after one year I have
four bunnies after two years I have
eight after three years I have 16 you
can see this is getting bigger for years
I have 32 bunnies and very quickly I
have to zoom out because this is growing
so fast
so I've 32 bunnies now after four years
then I have 64 128 256 512 1024 and 2048
bunnies after 10 years starting with two
bunnies okay and this is just gonna keep
growing and growing and growing that's
what bunnies do and actually in Seattle
this year last year we had a massive
explosion of bunnies they were
everywhere we had bunnies living in
every single bush in our neighborhood
the next year we had coyotes actually
okay so but exponential growth looks
like this and the basic idea here you
can actually write this as an equation
essentially you have X at time k plus 1
equals R times X so X is the bunny
population XK is the bunny population in
year k and XK plus 1 is the bunny
population the next year and R is how
much the bunny population increases from
year to year so in our case we have R
equals 2 because the bunny population
doubles each year okay this is super
cool this is a really really simple
mathematical expression that says that
essentially the amount of bunnies
the rate at which bunnies grow is
proportional to how many bunnies there
are that makes sense if two bunnies
double I get two more but if a thousand
bunnies double I get a thousand more and
that's what this is saying is that the
bigger my population is the faster it's
going to grow and that's why you get
this exponential growth okay so I'm not
telling you anything you didn't already
know and we're just kind of writing it
down as an equation here and oftentimes
it's useful instead of plotting kind of
on these linear axes like what we're
used to where every tick is the same
spacing oftentimes it's useful to plot
in these log coordinates so the y axis
now is like a log logarithmic ly spaced
so every tick in the Y Direction I'm
actually taking a bigger and a bigger
and a bigger step so from 2 to 8 for 8
to 32 32 to 128 every time I go up in
the Y I'm multiplying by 4 I'm not just
adding more more bunnies I'm multiplying
the number of buddies that's what
logarithmic coordinates do and so if you
take that same population growth where
after one year I have for bunnies after
two years I have eight and so on and so
forth you see that on these log
coordinates your exponential growth
turns into this nice straight line and
this is much easier to visualize and to
see kind of all of the scales of growth
over time in these log coordinates so
you're gonna see that a lot when you
look at data from a system that's
growing exponentially it's much more
useful to plot it this way than this way
oftentimes ok there's a really fun story
that I've always liked ever since I was
a little kid about exponential growth
just to give you kind of a feeling for
this there's the story about how chess
was invented and how the inventor of the
game of chess presented this to their
king and the king was so delighted
because this is such a great game of
strategy that he told the inventor and
you name the reward and I will grant it
to you and so the inventor of chess was
very clever maybe too clever and he said
here's my reward all I require all I ask
is that you give me one grain of wheat
for the first square and you give me two
grains of wheat for the second square
and four for the third square and double
the grains of wheat for every square now
the King thought this was a marvelous
deal immediately said yes that's a you
know that's a deal wonderful and it was
only weeks later when the king was told
that all of the grain areas were empty
and the kingdom was gonna starve and
that they couldn't pay the inventor that
they realized something was wrong
you know after 20 or 30 of these squares
you get into you know more grains of
wheat than there are in an entire
kingdom and doing what any reasonable
rational king would do at the time he
ordered the inventor executed as a
lesson to anyone else who would try to
outsmart a king now I've always loved
that story because it's such a simple
concept that if you double just a few
times you can get astronomical numbers
quickly and in fact astronomical and
there's this great Richard Fineman quote
that you know astronomical numbers used
to be really big
but now the national deficit is larger
than the number of stars in the galaxy
and so we should call them economical
numbers but I love this example because
it shows how big things get fast when
you double when you exponentiate okay
another example that I like to talk
about is you know things don't just grow
exponentially they can also decay
exponentially so this is a case of
radioactive decay where if you had a
radioactive element if you had some mass
of you know plutonium or uranium or
whatever
XK and I'm gonna pick an element a
magical element that has a half-life of
exactly one year then from year to year
you would take your mass and divide it
by two and that would tell you kind of
how that radioactive material changes in
time so if you start with 40 grams of
this material the next year you'll have
20 grams the next year you'll have 10
and five and so on and so forth
and very rapidly you'll have a miniscule
amount of this radioactive material just
because of the power of exponential
decay okay
so dividing by two a lot also gets you
very very small numbers just like
multiplying by two got you really really
big numbers okay except I think this is
kind of fun if you take enough of these
radioactive elements and you put them
really really close together when one of
them decays it might hit two others and
cause them to decay and those two others
cause for others to decay and very
quickly if you have a critical mass you
end up achieving fission and you get
again exponential growth until all of
that material has has kind of decayed or
fissioned
in this explosion okay so I think that's
kind of a fun example so there are two
extremes you can have exponential growth
where your population doubles you can
have exponential decay where your
population population halves most of my
examples I'm going to talk over here
about this kind of growth but you know
it's really the same mathematical
equation just with a different constant
from year to year okay and then going
back to Moore's law of you know
increasing density of transistors in
computers or the increasing number of
transistors and computers you can see
that over decades over you know out of
five decades this is very very nicely
followed this log linear progression so
you'll notice here the y-axis is on a
logarithmic scale and so the fact that
this is linear in these logarithmic
coordinates means that the number of
transistors has been exponential for
over 50 years which is remarkable more
define this law in 1965 with
this much information and it's been true
for the for the next 50 years I mean
that blows my mind that Moore's law is
true first of all but the more predicted
it that far ago very cool I love this
quote by Sir Arthur Conan Doyle because
it kind of explains Moore's law in a way
the more we progress the more we tend to
progress and this is true in most fields
of science and technology is that the
larger our scientific our base of
knowledge is the faster our knowledge
grows the larger our technological base
is the faster our technology grows and
so he says we draw a compound interest
on the capital of knowledge which has
been accumulated since the dawn of time
and I think that's just an absolutely
wonderful sentiment and quote and it
really does explain a lot of what we
observe in science and technology ok
exponential growth of money I think this
is really cool you know ever since I was
a little kid
I've loved numbers I've loved big
numbers and part of what fascinated me
and got me excited about math you know
even when I was a little little kid was
money and just kind of playing with you
know dollars and cents I thought this
was super fun and so this is one of my
favorite examples of exponential growth
and I'm going to use this in future
examples so I want to walk through a
really really simple toy example where
we're going to have $100 and we're going
to put it in a bank okay and we're going
to assume that we have a really great
bank that gives a 5 percent return each
year okay that's I haven't I haven't
found that Bank but let's say we have a
bank that will give us a 5 percent
return each year but I'm not gonna
reinvest my returns okay so in the first
year I have $100 and after one year I
have a hundred and five dollars but when
I'm going to assume is that I'm gonna
take that five dollars and I'm gonna
spend it I'm gonna buy some gum or some
coffee or something okay and then I'm
gonna take my base $100 and I'm gonna
get another five dollars after the next
year and I'm gonna spend that one and
then after the next year I'll get
another five dollars and so on and so
forth and after 40 years what you can
expect is that you will have a cue
amount of money of $300 you have your
original hundred dollars and then every
year for 40 years you get another five
dollars because of that interest but you
didn't reinvest that five dollars okay
so three hundred dollars total and I'm
picking 40 years because that is kind of
a reasonable work span if you start
working at 25 and you stop working at 65
you have a good 40 years to kind of
invest and to make money on your money
okay this is not reinvesting there's no
compound growth here but if you reinvest
that five dollars you make every year
something magical happens okay so now
we're going to take the same Bank but
every time we get five dollars we're
gonna put that back in the bank and it's
gonna compound interest
okay so the first year nothing changes I
go from a hundred dollars two hundred
and five I made five dollars exactly the
same but after the second year that five
dollars is also getting 5% interest and
so instead of one hundred and ten
dollars I get one hundred and ten
dollars and one quarter now that doesn't
seem like a big deal that extra quarter
you might leave that on the ground if
you were walking by but this extra
quarter makes all the difference in the
world over 40 years over 40 years what
I'll get is 704 total dollars in my bank
account if I reinvest that five that
five percent every year and so that's
pretty remarkable if I don't reinvest I
get three hundred dollars if I do
reinvest I get more than twice as much
return after 40 years and this is the
miracle of compound interest and
exponential growth and it's something
that still fascinates me I think it's
really easy for us to think that that
quarter doesn't make a difference but it
makes a huge difference and I'd like
this Einstein quote because this kind of
you know Einstein was was a Titan you
know he he did great things in physics
and his quote you know compound interest
is the eighth wonder of the world he who
understands that earns it he who doesn't
pays it and I think that's really cool
that you know he recognized how powerful
compound interest is dry
markets it drives economies it shapes
the world we live in it it defines who
whose money grows and who's doesn't and
I think that's kind of cool
so if you go back to this plot of the
long-term growth in the gross domestic
product the GDP of the US we see that
this really is very nearly exponential
in time even if you account for great
depressions and recessions and stock
market crashes and if you plot this in
log coordinates like what we've been
talking about you see that you get this
very nice log linear growth in in the
GDP okay so that just gives you a flavor
for some of the many many systems that
exhibit exponential growth if you look
at bacteria in a petri dish for a while
they will grow exponentially if you look
at a disease that crosses a continent
and it goes to a fresh population it's
gonna grow exponentially for a time lots
and lots of systems grow exponentially
and so in the next videos I'm gonna tell
you about why it's called exponential
growth what is X what is the exponential
we're going to talk about Euler and
Euler's constant E and I'm also going to
talk to you about what causes
exponential growth to eventually stop
growing exponentially nothing can really
grow exponentially forever so we're
going to talk about kind of what
curtails exponential growth so that's
all coming up all right thank you